una carta de 14 páginas dirigidas al
congresista Burning Thompson en la que
dice que no solamente esta investigación
es una falsa sino una cacería de brujas
y que le está haciendo daño al público
estadounidense tratando de dividirlo le
pidió a Thompson y al comité que
investigue el fraude electoral masivo
que hubo en el 2022 y no se refirió
concretamente a la la situación que le
hace este comité para que declare su
responsabilidad en La Toma del Capitolio
el 6 de enero del año pasado resaltó que
él sí autorizó a la fuerza Pública para
que se desplegara por la ciudad para
evitar Precisamente lo que ocurrió ese
día pero que fue Nancy feroz y la
alcaldesa de Washington murió el boxer
los que se demoraron a la hora de
reaccionar frente a las manifestaciones
finalmente resaltó precisamente las
personas que acudieron a esta marcha las
llamó patrióticas y pues esto obviamente
va a generar y está genera muchas
reacciones en el país Cristóbal y sie
Trump se niega acudir a esta situación
que poder tiene el comité para obligarlo
a comparecer puede lograr algo más que
un golpe de efecto
Pues en realidad lo que están diciendo
analistas acá en Washington Es que esto
se llevará a otra pelea legal más en la
que pues sus abogados trataran de
demorar esto y demorar esto después de
las elecciones legislativas donde se
espera que los republicanos el partido
de Donald Trump gane la mayoría en la
cámara de representantes y este es el
caso pues simplemente tumbarían esta
situación y Donald Trump no tenía no
tendría que pues declarar ante el
congreso frente a su eventual y posible
responsabilidad en lo que pasó el 6 de
enero del 2021